*INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS*
WHERE IS IT?
(I don't think its there pewds)
WHERE IS IT????
WHERE IS IT GOD DAMMIT??
WHERE IS IT?
*strange grunts*
Now we can begin the vlogs
Swedish boy goes to America!
Marzia: Are you gonna wear that all the time?
*sounds of pleasure* Oh my god yes
Okay, so Birdabo
We've decided that we're gonna do a challenge
So who can wear this stupid shirt
Marzia: So, does everybody have the same one?
Everyone has the same one. Me, Brad and Michael
Marzia: But they are not Swedish
Well they have to wear the shirt!
I'll explain more of the rules later but all you need to know is that
If I'm caught not wearing this shirt, I get a strike
Marzia: What happens after 3 strikes?
I'LL EXPLAIN LATER, I TOLD YOU
Marzia: OKAY OKAY
JESUS
Where's my shoe?
Marzia: Why do you keep losing your shoes today?
You took it
Marzia: I didn't take it!
There's no way you didn't take it
Tell me where it is
She took- she took my running shoes this morning
Marzia: I didn't!
And I was looking forever and now she took my other shoe
Marzia: I didn't take your running shoes
Well, okay fine I'm going out like this
Marzia: Okay bye
Bye
I swear this is the most annoying shit
To walk with one shoe
Where did she put it?
(camera is upside down)
She said under the bed
Oh my god, THERE it is
Stupid, stupid, stupid
Marzia: What did you say? Are you hating on me?
No -.-
Said only nice things
Why did you hide my shoe? You know-
It just started raining
LA never rains, are you serious?
How? How is this happening?
Gabbles do something
Man, I look like such a fucking asshole with this outfit. I just realised
21 days
Oh boy
We just arrived to LA today, or last night
And I'm so jet lag
and I feel like shit
As always
So I'm excited for the vlogs!
*Nice music plays*
Okay, so we're going grocery shopping
I feel like I'm gonna get shot wearing this, I don't know
Does it mean anything else here?
I feel like all the American vloggers
Cause they always- they always vlog at the grocery store
Im here for the people
Spray cheese, I'm already grossed out
EUK
Jesus Christ
(close your eyes and listen)
How big, do you need?
(10 INCHES)
It's fucking crazy, the sizes
I've never seen them this big
Jesus
Here we go, 12 years
Single malt
It's empty, it's empty
*more nice music*
So, I have a set up while I'm in
LA!!!
Razer hooked me up
Thank you Razer
Love you guys
So much
<3
Is this a Razer de- Oh IT IS
OOOOOOO
That looks nice, that looks very nice
OOOHHHH
WHOAA
DAMN
That looks sick!
That looks prettier than mine what the fuck what is all this
Is it liquid cooling?
It all works
Beautiful, thank you so much Razer for hooking me up
I was worried not having my set up when I'm away
But this is fucking awesome
Hell to the YEAAHH
I eh- got a better vlogging camera
It's definitely not a vlogging camera
It's a very nice camera
Eh the quality is amazing so I'm really excited to try to use it
Let's- let's hook it up
*music plays*
Aww, ohhh
OHHH NO
OHHH
Oh no
I packed the wrong bag
(uh oh spaghettios)
This is the wrong bag
Fucking
God fucking damn it
(Are you okay pewds)
*sighs*
I don't believe it
I don't have the- any of the SD cards
But I could buy them but I bought like a lot of them
Well this is the set up
It's suppose to have a tripod
I can't show you now because I don't have a SD card
God damn it
I wonder if this microphone works with that
This phone
This is the current situation
I'm so pissed
*fancy music plays*
Oh my god YES
No I found the SD cards
I don't know if you hear me in the camera
Vlogging, I'm probably way too close cause there's another tripod
Marzia: thats pretty good
Thats pretty good?
*cute Marzia blubber*
(i dont know what is being said here)
I bet everyone is gonna be like
'I preferred the cellphone- vlogging camera
Yeah,  WELL I SPENT A LOT OF MONEY ON THIS CAMERA
So you better- you better like it
Marzia: chill out man
weht the fuk did you fuking say man?
*Chill music plays*
If Brad and Michael isn't wearing them
I'm going to be seriously pissed
*more Marzia blubber*
Oh my god, BRAD IS NOT WEARING IT
Show me
That- Brad is not wearing his Swedish shirt
Yeah, you get your strike Brad
(HAHAHA BRAD!!)
We'll see, we'll see what he has to say later
I just got a text message from gubble
And he's told me that Brad is
live streaming
But he's not wearing the shirt
THAT'S 2 STRIKES BRAD
Thank you Gubble, thank you Gubble
So Brad has 2 strikes
FUCK YEAH
This makes me so happy
First day, 2 strikes
*back to the fancy music*
I'm making meatballs tonight
We're doing this Swedish theme
It's the only dish I know how to cook
We have 5 bags
But no handles, and we have to walk back
(you're screwed)
We're screwed
what are we doing?
Marzia: i dunno
Good luck Marzia
Marzia: thank you
*fancy fanCY FANCY!!!!*
You made it
Marzia: yay
My arms!
OOOF
Me and Gubble is just gonna chill for an hour
And then I got to start coooking cause Brad, Emma and Michael
are coming over
Tomorrow is the first day of Scare Pewdiepie shoot
And
I'm a little nervous
Going through all this fucking shit again
Episode 1 will be shot on Halloween
It's Halloween guys
*poses*
Time to cook meatballs!
Meatballs, yes
*NON-INTENSELY THROWS FOODS ON TO COUNTER TOP*
( pewds an intellectual: tosses foods on to counter top)
*THROWS INTENSELY*
We got
traditional meatballs
And then we got pussy meatballs
Marzia: Wow
For Marzia
who's a vegetarian
This is the meatball- the base of the meatball
And this is a giant ass onion
How do you make them so big America, what the f-
What do you put in your onions?
Marzia: What you doing in there?
Scare Pewdiepie
Marzia: Hey, make sure you don't touch my fake meat with your dirty meat
OHH
Brad: you started the challenge without us?
Yes, I fucking did
You have 3 strikes you fucking bitch
Where is your shirt?
Brad: I didn't know this was the start. Do I get a strike?
You have 3. You have 3
Brad: why do i have three?
We checked your instagram, your twitch
I was watching you stream
Brad: I MADE UP THE RULES
I WORE THIS SHIRT THE WHOLE DAY
What are you? Stupid? Why would you not wear the shirt?
Oh, and Michael is here. Is he wearing the shirt?
YOU CAN'T SEE THE FLAG!! Oh you get a strike!
You get a strike. You have to honor the flag
You think I can just wear a sweater over it? No
You get a strike, you both have strikes
Micheal: i was scared to get shot
Why would you get shot?
Michael: Because it's blue!
Micheal: everyone one told me i shouldn't wear blue
How dare you wear that Swedish flag, you haven't-
No don't touch me
Brad is going to try the Scandinavia delight
Brad: Something called Scandinavia delight which is fruit flavoured
And going with a meatball
*Brad is grossed*
Brad: what is wrong with your cooking?
How dare you
Brad: whoa man that weird
My own meatballs?
Micheal: and the Scandinavian delight
I mean, it's good
There's nothing to react to it, it's just good
You don't like it, you're wrong
How was the Scandinavian meatballs?
Brad:Horrible
Brad: Oh the meatball was good but-
FUCK YOU
Marzia: okay, explain to us why you guys have matching shirts
Well- why don't. eh okay. well
First of all, 3- 4 strikes now
( come on Brad v.v )
Cause you're not wearing the shirt
Well, you obstruct the video
Salty Brad: you cheated and its crazy
There's 21 more days of Birdabo
We have to wear the shirt in every shot
If you see us, not wearing the shirt, we get a strike
Brad has 4 strikes, how does that feel?
Clap it up for Brad everyone
*claps for the salty bean named Brad*
Good job Brad
You came up with this idea
Salty Brad: You see this thing we're filming right now?
the agreement that we put the shirts on in the shot for the first time
and they both conspired against me
poopie: you have four strikes thats all that matters
Salt: CONSPIRED AGAINST ME  TO SHOW UP-
POODS: okay why dont you tell them what happens if you- the most strikes
after 21 days
Brad: after 21 days, has to go to a cheap tattoo parlor and get an american flag tattoo
( good luck Brad ^3^ )
and you're WINNING
all together: YEAH!!!!
Brad: so basically you're going to cheat so much
you're going to work together against me
that i have to get the tattoo
poopie: thats already what's happening
Marzia: wait, Micheal doesn't have any tattoos
poods and the salt/Brad: yeah, he doesn't have any tattoos
Marzia: that can be his first
Micheal: my first shouldn't be this one
Brad: thats right it shouldn't be
poopie: i think if you get more than a certain amount of strikes we get to pick...
where you get the tattoo
(GET IT ON YOUR BUTT!!!!!!)
Okay well thats birdabo for you everyone
get out of here!
shoosh
Salt Brad: you're a cheater
BIRDABO
Episode one, hope you guys enjoyed it!
it was weird to be back vlogging
but i think its fun anyway
i'll see you tommorow
WITH ANOTHER EPISODE, first day shooting Scare Pewdiepie
as always, *whispers* Brofist
* end of birdabo video
you can click out...
OR WATCH MORE VIDEOS!!!
PEWDS REALLY NEEDS MORE VIEWS AND SUBS
make 10 accounts and no joke
I REPEAT THIS IS NOT A SCAM
YOU WILL RECEIVE YOUR VERY OWN GUBBLE!!!
so make sure you sub to this small channel
or die.
your choice...
no pressure.
these are nice pictures.
* fancy music*
still here?
Thank you!!
welll...okay...bye bye...
#saltyBrad